I'm told that during a scene things got
a little edgy didn't intend to get edgy
you shot a scene with his right Sarah
Paulson Yeah right and Jessica Lange and
well things didn't go quite the way you
thought they would
yeah essentially well it was terrible I
I basically am leaned over Jessica
Lange's desk in a hospital gown yes
bare ass yeah thank you but but so I put
a sock on cut say yeah
[Applause]
that's a turn that's a term yes rather
crest erm sorry
yeah yeah it's Andy prefers it's fairly
self-evident though what he means
yeah from sock yes yeah yes thank you
Andy sure so it it's supposed to cover
the entire genital region well yeah yeah
but I I put it on and and we did the
scene and and afterwards Sarah comes up
to me kisses me on the cheek ins like
all sweetheart it's okay and I was like
what what's was I that bad and and then
I look over at miss Lange's telling the
the PA that apparently my balls were in
her face the whole so they were not
covered apparently a sock is not just a
yeah and by right
so lesson learned lesson learned
Oh so yes you didn't you thought okay
ice yeah you got to swoop down and she
the balls yes as well
hey let's could you draw this and then
you need a thing that goes yeah tape it
yeah and then tape it there not to take
okay all right and I'm gonna be selling
this tape on eBay fantastic all right
well we can't show that sorry
it actually he just looks like a mouse
running into a net
you